[Music]
all right hi everybody I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Rubin report it's October
11th 2023 as always we're on Rumble
local Spotify all the usual spots uh
more than ever now I would say please do
uh join us on rumble or locals so that
you can get me directly because as you
know we live in a time of censorship and
I suppose telling the truth these days
is not uh that comfortable for a certain
set of people that run big Tech and Lord
only knows how long we will remain on
YouTube so if you could jump over to
rumble.com rubben report or Ruben
report.com locals that would uh be great
as always we've got a postgame show
after the show today uh today obviously
there's just like a ton of news to catch
up on and what's going on obviously in
Israel and how that relates to American
foreign policy and some of the domestic
things going on here uh so I'm going to
recap that for just a bit at the top of
the show today
and uh in about 15 minutes or so we have
former US ambassador to Israel David
fredman he was the Ambassador under
Donald Trump I'm sure many of you
remember I interviewed him uh at the
Western Wall in Jerusalem just about 6
months ago in May when we when we took
that trip to Israel uh he's a great
American he's a great supporter of
Israel and I think and and he was really
the architect or at least the the force
the real driving force on the ground
behind the a abam Accord so this is a
guy who knows a little something uh
about history and a little something
about peace uh so he's going to check in
with us he is in Jerusalem right now at
his home uh before we get to the show
you know a lot I just two quick things
um I I've gotten more comments and
emails and texts from friends and from
people that I haven't heard from in 20
years and a whole bunch more uh for the
about the shows that we've done for the
last couple days then in my entire
career uh and I'm just trying to do what
I think is right and I appreciate it and
we appreciate you guys so I just wanted
to make note of that and I think people
sort of can see that there's a little
bit of a different tone in the show the
last couple days than they're than
they're usually is um and hopefully we
will get back to to the other tone
because I I do dig that one too but this
is important uh that's number one and
number two uh a lot of you are asking me
where to donate I've made a couple
different donations uh but a group that
is in Miami that uh helps out a lot of
Israelis and they are uh they are
raising money for the Frontline IDF
officers that are fighting now they are
raising money directly for the
families that have been affected and we
don't have to get into the Litany of
horrific things that they're going to
going through uh it's called heart h e a
r t heart hands in effort for action and
relief today uh I just donated $110,000
it's just the beginning of I donated a
couple other things it's not important
but like it's it's important and if you
have the means uh it's appreciated and
uh we are fighting for Western
Civilization here truly so uh the link
is in the description um so please uh if
you've got the means as I said uh do let
us know uh okay let's uh let's get to
the top here Phoenix
um give me just a sec guys we're rolling
through through some things here all
right so look uh you guys know that I've
had some uh issues uh with former
president Donald Trump lately right like
I haven't liked some of the behavior and
all that but I was a huge supporter of
him I I took the the arrows for that uh
and I've always said if this thing all
ends with tantis as my Governor here in
Florida and president and Trump as my
president like things will be just fine
because things were a lot better under
Donald Trump period domestically we know
it whether we're talking about our
border or whether we're talking about uh
financially the economy and all those
things and certainly foreign policy it
it's it's night and day there isn't even
a Chasm that I could show you that would
be wide enough uh to see how different
these things are and we are now seeing
the difference between a strong
president uh on the foreign policy state
on the world stage and and a weak
president who nobody believes is really
um in charge of his administration so
I'm going to compare and contrast that
add in a couple other uh little details
over the last day or so and then we will
get to Ambassador fredman uh before all
that real quick I want to talk to you
guys about Bambi uh you guys know that
when running a business your employees
can create all kinds of interesting
situations like getting complaints
because someone on the team always
smells horrible well you better talk to
Bambi with Bambi get access to your own
dedicated HR manager start at just $99
per month they're available by phone
email and realtime chat so onboarding
and terminations run smoothly team
members reach Peak Performance and your
business stays compliant with changing
HR regulations and with Bambi's HR
autopilot you'll automate important HR
practices like setting policies training
and feedback HR managers can easily cost
80 grand a year but Bambi starts at 99
bucks per month schedule your free
conversation today to see how much Bambi
can take off your plate go right now to
bambi. comom and type in Ruben under
podcast and you'll when you sign up
it'll help the show B
mbe.com bambi. comom type in Ruben under
podcast and now back to me okay so I
want to start quickly because you know
this thing is not just about politics
and I always tell you that great Andrew
Breitbart line that politics is
Downstream from culture so I want to
start with a very quick clip from Joe
Rogan show yesterday because Joe is not
known for his geopolitical analysis and
he's kind of what put him on the map
really is that he's just a decent guy
trying to have conversations with people
uh he made an interesting uh comment
yesterday on his show about anti-war
liberals and how they actually might
become magga people in this next
election it seems to me like the more
time goes on Trump trump is a shoe
in it seems like if this gets
getting crazier and crazier there's
going to be a lot of liberals that'll
vote for him he was the one in the
beginning we got to stop people from
dying like when do you want Ukraine to
win this war remember that conversation
he's like I want people to stop dying
like which is the best answer any
politician has ever given and the way he
said it and isn't that the Simplicity of
Donald Trump right again for all the
criticisms and all the stuff and the
name calling it's like that's the
Simplicity of Donald Trump that's the
reason people hear him talk and like him
uh it's as simple as that and and what's
interesting about that clip is you guys
know for the last year what have I been
saying ad nauseum the the slim group of
people who maybe can move one way or the
other from Democrat to Republican or
republican to Democrat the slim group is
the disaffected liberal and I'm seeing
an awful lot of them an awful lot of
them who over the last couple years have
said some pretty horrible things about a
guy like me uh they're now waking up
they're going boy you know when you see
a whole bunch of people with Nazi signs
at Palestinian rallies in New York City
you suddenly go oh maybe maybe the
people who were criticizing the left
were kind of right and oh maybe there is
an answer and my God that man's orange
but I might have to vote for him uh
here's a quick clip from from Trump this
is a day or two ago uh talking about
what the world was like when he was
president when I was your President we
had peace through strength and now we
have weakness conflict and Chaos the
atrocities we're witnessing in Israel
would never have happened if I was
President would never have ever happened
when I was commander-in-chief we reduced
the Iranian economy and I withdrew from
the disastrous Iran nuclear deal imposed
the toughest ever sanctions on the
regime and imposed a strict travel ban
to keep radical Islamic terrorists the
hell out of our country now they're
pouring into our country they're pouring
into our
country yeah I mean he's just right and
there's no doubt about it he would not
have released the $6 billion to Iran
which they said was going to be for
humanitarian purposes and then we played
you the clip two weeks ago the Iranian
president said well we're going to just
do whatever we want with it and then
here we are two weeks later right
beheading of children right you see the
connection so he makes a good point on
that he makes another good point we
would have never withdrawn from
Afghanistan the way we did and now it
does sound like some of those weapons
that we left over somehow making their
way over to the Middle East I mean all
of these things and then of course the
next step of this which may be uh for
those of you that might look at the
Middle East and go okay I don't care
about that far off Place uh what happens
there actually affects us because if we
don't have a border we have no idea who
has walked into this country so when you
when you see these people at these
rallies uh you have to wonder where
their allegiances lie and what they
would do if they had the power to go
after anyone here who believes in
Freedom and individual rights in our
Constitution and all of those things so
let's contrast that a little bit with
our current president uh first I want to
throw back to something that Joe Biden
said uh not too long ago this is at
college graduation and then we'll
contrast it with what he said yesterday
which actually uh was pretty decent I
suppose but here he is not too long ago
on the biggest threat to the United
States to single out as the most most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white
supremacy one of the things I think is
important I wish I wish we taught more
in our schools about the Islamic
faith that's interesting right so okay
white supremacy is the biggest threat we
all know that that's just abject
nonsense when they say white supremacy
they basically mean Maga they mean Trump
supporters that is not to say that there
are not some white supremacists and they
should be called out and marginalized
but we know it is simply not and then of
course the secondary video that we
should be teaching more about the
Islamic faith is just sort of bizarre
because I'm fairly certain in all of the
Islamic countries they're not running
around going hey could we teach more
about Judaism how about Christianity
could we get in on that uh anyway Biden
did finally speak yesterday now keep in
mind there are I think 11 we know of 11
and the numbers obviously are changing
and it's a little unclear 11 at least 11
American hostages right now somewhere in
Gaza uh there's been basically no call
to free these people uh but Biden did
give a speech yesterday and for for Joe
Biden who I'm very critical of it was
fairly clear Hamas does not stand for
the Palestinian people's right to
dignity and
self-determination the state of purpose
is the annihilation of the state of
Israel and the murder of Jewish
people let there be no doubt the United
States has Israel's back we'll make sure
the Jewish and Democratic state of
Israel can defend itself today tomorrow
as we always have it's as simple as that
all right look the message was basically
right you know the the hard part about
Biden right now is because we all know
he's not running the show right he's not
the captain of the ship that it's like
where is this coming from and are you
guys going to take any of the blame for
what got us here because it's his
policies I mean this is just true this
is not partisan it is his policies that
got us here we've got a compilation
right now of Biden Administration
officials uh explaining some of their
poor policies regarding Iran aren't
going to be released for nothing in
exchange didn't they also get five
Iranians they will get five uh Iranians
as well yeah Jackie why we need to add6
billion dollar on top of
that this is the deal that we were able
to strike Biden's Ransom payment will be
immediately used to stoke violence blood
Ed and Mayhem throughout the Middle East
putting Israel the United States and the
entire world in very grave Peril 6
billion they W released and they're
going to have chice they're going to use
it for humanitarian Aid there's no
guarantees of that so I'm very much
concerned about this so we're looking
into it much deeper but I'm very
concerned do you have concern that money
is funable there is obviously money is
fungible the administration says this is
limited to humanitarian aid but they
also acknowledge that funds are fungible
which means they can you move them
around and will Aid them in being able
to do other things so people are are
very concerned it seems you know very
clear to the critics in both sides on
the hill money is fungible that's the
criticism and now president reesi has
added fuel to the fire that already
existed of criticism by saying we're
going to do anything we want with it but
isn't it true that this frees Teran up
to spend more on other nefarious goals
like supporting terrorism and boosting
its nuclear program and it's you know I
I can't predict what they'll do going
forward here Iran may have known this
money is coming and used other funds to
help fund this attack that happened Iran
has Iran has unfortunately always used
and focused its funds on supporting
terrorism on supporting groups like uh
like
Hamas I assure you guys we could have
shown you a way longer compilation of
the confusions and outright lies and
obfuscations from this Administration
related to that you can thank me for not
showing you anything from Karin jeanpier
I love this phrase money is fungible and
that they all start repeating it of
course it is you're not going to believe
this I pay all the guys in this room uh
guys you do whatever you want with the
money right you don't ask me when you're
having lunch or you're buying your chick
something or yeah everybody money's
fungible you give it to somebody they
can do what they want with it uh anyway
just just a little bit more than I want
to get to the Ambassador uh here is a
tweet and it's interesting there's
something so fascinating happening right
now Elon Musk this cannot be overstated
he in some respects is saving Western
Society right now I don't think this was
his intention when he bought Twitter I
think it might have been sort of in a in
a Kind of Blue Sky way uh but by
allowing people to get information
directly and allowing people to see the
horrors and then also expose the bad
guys who are all too willing to expose
themselves uh we would not have that if
Elon Musk did not have Twitter right we
know that the censorship and the Banning
and all of those things you would they
would be banning and suspending the good
guys and promoting the bad guys but some
of the bad guys are still on there and
it's an interesting philosophic debate
on as to what Elon should do about these
things but I think it is good to know uh
what some of the genuinely bad guys are
saying here is Iranian supreme leader
Ali
CI uh that video that he linked to
before I read the Tweet is from the uh
the desert the party where 250 Israeli
kids I mean you know teenagers and and
20-some year olds were killed who were
just going to a a concert he wrote God
Willing the cancer of the usurper
Zionist regime will be eradicated at the
hands of the Palestinian people and the
resistance forces through the region now
look there's you can have a debate like
is that a direct threat to Israel should
he be allowed to be on these platforms
again I sort of think exposing these
things is the best I want to throw you
to a map you know we've shown you a map
a couple different maps of the Middle
East I saw this one this morning Ben
Shapiro tweeted this one out just again
showing you the scale of what we are
talking about we are talking about a
tiny country that red box you're looking
at there the box is probably four times
the size of what Israel actually is it's
the little speck in the box but you
can't even make a box small enough uh
but only if that country was a little
bit smaller we would had have peace that
that seems to be the argument and I
think most people realize it isn't but
Cain is not the only one uh
internationally saying crazy things uh
this is a a tweet from turkey's Deputy
minister of National Education uh he
said one day they will shoot you too you
will die uh that seems like a direct
threat to BB Netanyahu and then now just
a little bit more catching you up and
then we'll bring on the Ambassador uh
this is from the AP uh now the outbreak
of the war between Israel and the
Palestinians after after a devastating
Hamas attack on Israeli soil is
threatening to delay or derail the years
long country by country diplomatic Push
by the United States to improve
relations between Israel and its Arab
neighbors the so-called normalization
push which began under former president
Donald Trump's Administration and was
branded as the Abraham Accords is an
ambitious effort to reshape the region
and boost Israel's standing in historic
ways Secretary of State Anthony blinkin
said the Hamas attacks may have been
driven in part by a desire to Scuttle
the United States most ambitious part of
the initiative the sealing of diplomatic
relations between Rivals Israel and
Saudi Arabia the middle east's two great
Powers share a common enemy in Iran a
generous military and financial sponsor
of Hamas however social media showed
crowds take to the streets with
Palestinian Flags in Lebanon Bahrain
Kuwait and elsewhere in the hours after
the Hamas attack a policeman in Egypt's
coastal city
coastal city of Alexandria open fire on
Israeli tourists killing two Israelis
and one Egyptian Saudi Arabia's foreign
minister Ministry in a statement soon
after the attacks did not condemn Hamas
instead the ministry noted that it had
repeatedly warned that Israel's
occupation the deprivation of the
Palestinian people of their legitimate
rights and the repetition of systemic
provoc provocations provocation sorry uh
led to this moment White House National
Security spokesman John Kirby declined
to to comment on the Saudi response and
with no further Ado having caught you up
on some of that and Ambassador I Ser I
seriously hope that I'm doing Justice uh
to all of the the things that you have
been fighting for I welcome uh my friend
uh former US ambassador to Israel David
fredman to the show Ambassador how are
you Dave I'm fine I've been better but
I'm fine and uh I wish I could say the
same thing for so many people in Israel
who are not fine I mean a lot of a lot
of them are not fine and uh and you know
why we don't need to go through all the
creade of Horrors that we've seen over
the last few days but uh we're really
not fine it's it's it's it is a it's a
day of Holocaust it's not the Holocaust
in its scope but the day that day of
October 7th was a day uh that the Jewish
people experienced during the Holocaust
and it's a day that we never thought
we'd see again and so um uh the people
of Israel are in pain but they're also
incredibly United incredibly determined
incredibly angry and and they are going
to respond I think like never before
well actually on that note if you don't
mind Ambassador you posted a video of
young Israelis who are returning to
Israel at this very moment to defend
their country and their people and their
families I'd like to throw to that real
quick because maybe that'll give us a
little more of a positive note to to
start
on
[Applause]
[Music]
Ambassador that Spirit young people
returning home to defend their families
May maybe uh Hamas has awoken something
that needed to be awoken in in some
bizarre spiritual
sense they have I mean these are uh
these are young Israelis on vacation in
various parts in the world uh they were
collected you know from whatever their
meeting point was and uh they're not
complaining about having their vacations
cut short they're coming uh they they're
they're joining their brothers in Israel
and brothers and sisters in Israel
they're on this plane they're singing am
Israel which means the nation of Israel
lives and uh and by the way that's uh
that's emblematic of the entire country
I mean what I'm seeing in Israel um uh
apart from the pain and the pain is real
but um but those who are not mourning
today or at least not mourning directly
for an immediate member of their family
those who don't have someone who's being
held hostage and unfortunately that's
those are hundreds of people but the
people the rest of the country they are
determined uh they are rushing they
they're they're tripping over each other
uh to get into into battle to get into
to get to the front lines uh the people
who are not in the Army anymore people
like me who are too old to serve in the
Army uh doing acts of kindness uh
raising money
philanthropy uh you know putting up
people who are displaced from the north
to the South because their they had to
move out of their homes or their homes
were destroyed people were you know
they're just welcoming everybody into
their homes I mean this country uh uh
knows how to deal unfortunately knows
how to deal with the tragedy and they're
up to the task you know you know I have
to say Ambassador when I saw you 6
months ago it was the first time we ever
met and I interviewed you and you said
hey you want to take a walk around
Jerusalem and we had lunch and we walked
around and I said to you many times the
thing that I could not believe and
having been to Israel several times
before I could not believe how peaceful
it was and how safe it was and it it's
so personally I mean the tragedy is just
beyond imagination but I really thought
that the next time I was going to have
you on if you would have asked me last
week was going to be in a few weeks from
now to explain that this deal with Saudi
Arabia and Israel had been signed and
here we are but can you just talk a
little bit about the peaceful nature
that actually is in Israel for just a
moment I mean again we can talk about
the horrors all the time but something
incredible has been brewing there and
that's what's being prayed right
now look the the you know the the one
thing about the people of Israel and and
I wish we had this now in America but
there there are foundational principles
and you know foundational experiences
and commonality that not withstanding
the the the politics here which as you
know is all over the place and very
robust people get very upset and angry
and and you know about that but when it
comes down to it it's a family the
people here are a family many of them
are children and grandchildren of
Holocaust Survivors who came here as
their only place of refuge and they
understand I mean there's a there's an
expression in
hebu we have no other land and and
that's their view that's that's really
the motivating princip here there's no
place to go this is this is the last
stop this is where the Jewish people
take their stand and they stand for
their home they stand for their family
they stand for their their neighbors and
and and that's that's something that I
don't know that any other country has um
it's a sense of of of unity and and
camaraderie and Brotherhood and
Sisterhood that I don't think we have
anymore in America regrettably but but
it's still here and and that's what
contributes to the stability uh almost
all the time until until something like
this happens and then we realized we
realized something very painful which is
that um you know we had thought that um
that the Holocaust was you know as it
relates to the Jew the war against the
Jews was the war to end all wars and and
I think we you know we didn't really
believe it but we kind of felt that way
and optimistically felt that maybe the
Jewish people after 2,000 years are are
going to finally be allowed to live uh
in this land this god-given land this
only Jewish state in the whole world
this little as you point out on the map
little tiny Speck of dust on the globe
um we thought we could we could live
here in peace but we still can't we
still can't can't and and what I what I
say Dave to people when they ask me you
know to to describe this
moment um I call it a never again moment
you know the the phrase never again is
used by everybody uh of all Stripes you
know when it comes to the Holocaust
never again you know we use that word
those those those words they're
wonderful words they convey a real
meaning but now we're going to find out
you know are these just words yeah or is
there really something to it because now
is really where the rubber hits the road
on this issue this wasn't this wasn't a
terrorist attack this wasn't a battle
you know this was a this was a this was
a day of holocost this was
a you know the soldiers who came here
the these hard hardened battle tested
soldiers you know uh when they finally
exposed these places it was almost like
you remember Eisenhower when he was when
he and his troops came into the
concentration camps after the end of
World War II you know they they they
couldn't these are these are tough
people you know these are these are
really tough people they couldn't
contain you know they were they were
they were throwing up they were they
they couldn't contain there they they
were crying they couldn't believe that
human beings could be so cruel and
barbaric to each other and and that's
the kind of that's what the reaction
that that the Israeli soldiers um you
know diplomats even the Press I mean
everybody that went and visited
yesterday there was an open day of press
to come and look nobody nobody left
there uh unchanged I mean nobody and so
um this is is the time to find out who
we are who we really are you know are we
going to stand with Israel so that they
can defeat and eradicate this evil or
are we going to start kind of
micromanaging and and getting
politically correct and thinking about
well you know uh you know 1,200 people
were murdered you know should should
Israel be able to kill twice that many I
mean that that's the way the world has
traditionally thought we got to get we
got to get completely out of that
Paradigm and say this is a war for the
existence of the Jewish State it's
probably a war for the existence of the
Jewish people because if we lose this
who knows where this where this leads
and and we have to win this fight how
much of this do you think is because the
West does not know how to stand up for
itself it doesn't know its own history I
mean when I some of the things that I
see on Twitter and and even I mean MSNBC
which is almost a Hamas Network at this
point the absolute lies of the history
you know all these people saying the an
occupation began 75 years ago it's
really bizarre to have a bunch of
Palestinian people on MSNBC apparently
calling for the British Empire to come
back or bring back the Ottomans before
that or the idea that the Jews everyone
knows that Jews celebrate Hanukkah in
Judea and Samaria like all of the things
that I keep repeating ad nauseum that
that you know of course that the West
didn't know how to explain its history
and I would directly link that to a
problem we have in the United States
where we have half the people thinking
that our foundation was fundamentally
based in racism and not in the
individual rights and freedom and a
nation for all people and all that that
we've just lost it maybe out of out of
it's a function of our success I suppose
and that might stand you might be able
to say that for Israel and you might be
able to say that for the United
States yeah I think you're right I think
I think we have lost our way and um and
I think we've also lost we've lost our
way we' also lost some basic facts which
you know um for the benefit of your
audience if I could just point out the
fact you know people refer to Gaza as
the most densely populated place in the
world you know it's an open air prison
Gaza is 142 square miles right Manhattan
Island is 17th of that it's about 24
sare miles right so Manhattan Island
where where um 8 million people either
live there or come to work there every
day is 17th the size of Gaza right so
you know just in terms of understanding
the density now where is Gaza right it's
not landlocked Gaza has uh along its
border um a strip of the Mediterranean
that is the most beautiful beach in the
world it's the same Beach as as you
would have in Tel Aviv M we all know how
beautiful the beaches are in Tel Aviv so
the the Gaza has the potential to be a
place of Tourism to be a place of of
Commerce it's got um I can tell you I
used to go there when I was a kid in the
in the you know in the 80s and the 70s
it's a beautiful place it was beautiful
beautiful beachfront people used to come
there all the time and you know why is
it a place today where you wouldn't want
to live or I wouldn't want to live by
the way it's a place where corrupt
Palestinians want to live because
there's some mansion there on the water
that are spectacular but why would you I
want to live there well if there's
someone to blame okay it's not Israel
it's Hamas you know Hamas has destroyed
Commerce Hamas has destroyed you know
freedom of speech Hamas has destroyed
freedom of religion Hamas takes people
who were accused of being gay brings
them up to the top of a building and
throws them off Hamas is subjugating
women Hamas is destroying any
opportunity for engagement with the rest
of the world and primarily Hamas refuses
to accept the state of Israel and has as
part of its Charter a mandate to kill
the Jewish people so you ask yourself
well why aren't the people there you
know why aren't they enjoying some of
the economy that the Israelis enjoy why
aren't they
participating you know in in in tourism
that Israel because of Hamas because
Hamas doesn't permit it and so you know
um you know all these people that are
that are boning the fate of the gazin in
in the gazin Palestinians let me tell
you when Hamas is defeated they're going
to be liberated okay so all all the
people that want to help them if they
want to help them at all they should
help Israel in this war to defeat the
single Source that's keeping the gazin
down keeping them from achieving their
aspirations so you know the the facts
are just completely upside down in terms
of you you'd think in in a university
and you know you know we're watching um
you know places like Harvard and and you
know Colombia where I went to school and
NYU Law School where I got my law degree
you know the student organizations are
coming out and and think of what they're
saying they're saying that a woman
who was raped a a woman who was murdered
while she was pregnant and had her
stomach sliced open so that the fetus
could be pulled out and decapitated that
these people had it coming they had it
coming because they live in Israel which
is an apartheid state that's what these
people are saying at Harvard at Colombia
at the best schools you know it's it's
an indication that somehow SAT scores
are inversely proportional to
intelligence right I mean it's it's
unbelievable that people that presumably
you know have have some cerebral matter
can't get this can't even open up a book
and get the facts right so they can make
the right decisions and it's it's
massively frustrating but you know what
I don't care because we're going to win
this war whether people like it whether
they don't whether Harvard thinks it's a
good idea or a bad idea we're going to
win this war the Jewish people okay I
don't care whether you're leftwing
right-wing Center if you care about
Jewish survival you have to support
Israel in winning this war yeah and if I
could just add one thing to that I can't
say anything better than you just said
but it's not just you don't even have to
care about the Jews specifically if you
care about Western Civilization this is
it we're seeing it it's not that
surprising that a bunch of people that
don't know if boys or girls also don't
know if the people beheading babies are
the bad guys uh you know I want to throw
the map up for just another second
because could you uh from a from a
geopolitical and from a geographic uh uh
perspective explain this situation with
Egypt and Sinai uh now most people I
mean you don't hear this on MSNBC but
Gaza was in control uh by Egypt before
196 and then they lost it after
attacking Israel uh but that everyone
can see that map right there and there
is a border with Egypt that's Sinai
specifically that they're bordering with
basically nobody lives in siai and if
the pal if the Egyptians or the
jordanians or the syrians ETC if any of
these people actually cared about the
Palestinians wouldn't everybody be
saying boy you got to get away from
those crazy Jews how about you just walk
over the Border there but Egypt has
completely bombarded the
Border yeah I mean look um nobody no
body wants them uh and not only does
nobody want them but they are um they
are intentionally I Believe by suring by
Hamas certainly by the the radical
islamists they intentionally kept
suppressed so that they remain angry and
remain angry at Israel I mean this is
this is a this is a terrorist farm right
this is where terrorists are are taught
to be angry and to hate Israel I'll give
you an example you know we cut off
funding to an organization called anra
the United
[Music]
rels agency it's it's a refugee agency
it's the only Refugee agency in the
world that's earmarked specifically to
Palestinians right every other Refugee
agency just deals with refugees this
particular Agency for no particular
reason is focused only on Palestinians
and and we and if I may don't they don't
they don't they also do it for for it's
not just people that were displaced
let's say in the war in 1948 it's for
all of their children and grandchildren
everything else which doesn't apply to
any other people on the face of the
planet correct
their definition of refugees would would
extend to a plastic surgeon in Beverly
Hills you know who happens to be a
Palestinian origin so yeah it's it's
it's absurd but but understand what they
do I mean in these schools in Gaza and
and I you know you can find these on the
internet they they these schools put on
plays right and they dress up let's say
in a fourth grade play they'll dress up
half the kids as terrorists you know
with fake machine guns I assume fake
maybe just you know maybe just unloaded
and then they'll dress up the other half
the kids as Jews you know Jews they
they'll put them on big noses they'll
put them on yellow stars whatever
they'll they'll make clear that these
are Jews and then the terrorists you
know in the play they kill all the Jews
the Jews All Fall Down they act like
they're dead and the parents get up and
applaud right that's that's what unra
does I mean this is they've made no
effort whatsoever to to to in any way
teach you know coexistence with the
Israelis who were you know on their
along their border so you know one of
the problems is you know is is as in
almost every situation is you know who's
funding all this right you know and we
didn't fund it like we didn't we cut off
under completely um we cut off almost
the entire Aid to the Palestinian
Authority why because they they have a
system where they pay uh terrorists to
kill Jews the more Jews you kill the
more money you get so he said well if
that's what you're using your money for
God forbid the American people the
American tax payers should be funding
that so we cut that off and of course we
cut off funding to Iran which really is
really is the the head of the snake is
really coordinating all of this I mean
there's no way this um this attack could
have been possibly achieved without the
financing and the training the the the I
I believe the the Cyber attack
capabilities the um uh the organization
and the approval of the Islamic Republic
of Iran and so you know what are we
doing with Iran you know it's people are
debating it's I'm watching this debate I
I find it so amusing whether or not the
the $6 billion dollar that America gave
to Iran as part of the prisoner swap you
know they're debating whether or not
that money was actually used or spent on
this attack as if it matters you know as
if it matters and of course and it's not
just I mean of course money is fungible
you pointed that out as well but it's
even worse than that because this
problem existed long before the um this
particular prisoner swap I I'll I'll
I'll just you know I I I just want to
make sure here are some numbers that you
understand in um uh the um Iran Iran's
revenues from the export of crude oil
and uh and condens it reached $42.6
billion right in
2022 in 2021 the number was $25.5
billion and in 2020 right our last year
it was $7.9 billion so that's a almost a
six times six-fold increase in Iran's
oil revenues
over you know since the end of the Trump
Administration
now who cares about the 6 billion you
know that's in escro in Qatar they have
become incredibly Rich we have taken you
know the pressure off we have lifted
sanctions and it's and this is what this
is what you get I mean this is what you
get we've created a a financial pathway
a a lubricant if you will to all the
mine back activity in the Middle East
and elsewhere and it's not just the
Middle East I mean you know we have an
open border right we we have no idea who
in our country right now no idea and um
I sure hope it's not any of these people
but that would just be an optimistic
speculation I mean there's no reason to
think that there aren't you know lots of
people in America right now who are are
being funded by Iran so it's a problem
for America it's a problem for Israel
it's a problem as you point out it's a
problem for the Free World it's a
problem for the West it's for a problem
for any liberal democracy anyone who
values freedom and uh and opportunity
and this is the tip of the spere and and
this is where we find out you know
whether or not um you know Western
values are going to Prevail or whether
we're going to be in a quagmire with uh
with with the worst of the worst what do
you think America should be doing right
now so I think look I I think
that um what what I'd like them to do
which they won't do I don't believe is
to uh do an about face on Iran I mean
it's uh you know it's hard to admit
mistakes and politicians almost never do
that
um the guy I used to work for didn't
like to do it either so I'm not going to
pick on uh pick on Biden but but it's a
huge mistake and it's being proven to be
a huge mistake just like the Border has
been proven the open border has been
proven to be a huge mistake um they got
to get tougher on Iran um I I I think
they ought to go to the qataris just it
may only be a symbolic gesture but what
I would say to the qataris is um freeze
that money or give it back to us um you
got to understand something at the same
time the very same time
that the United States and Iran are
negotiating this five for five prisoner
swap with a $6 billion sweetener at the
same time um uh Hamas and Iran are
negotiate are planning this attack and
$6 billion according to the Americans
was a was a token of good faith I mean
which which which boggles my mind as if
as between America and Iran it's America
that has to show its good faith but in
any event we got duped I mean I assume I
sure hope I'm right about this I assume
that if America knew at the time it was
negotiating this prisoner swap that
Hamas and Iran were negotiating this
this this assault against the Jewish
people this barbaric attack reminiscent
of the Holocaust I would hope that
America would not have gone through with
this deal and assuming that's the case
and I sure hope it's true um they ought
to they ought to look the Iranians in
the eye and say you cheated us you duped
us give us back the money we're not
going to honor this deal you know we're
not going to take back we're not you
know we we can't take back the prisoners
because you have them already but we're
not sure as I'll not giving you the
money and uh I hope they do that now on
another front I'm gonna I'm going to say
I think that moving to Gerald Ford which
is the largest aircraft carrier in the
world moving that into the East
Mediterranean and I think Biden's speech
last night was helpful I mean if it
keeps Lebanon out of the war and I'm I'm
not sure that's going to happen but if
it does keep Lebanon out of the war
because because of the threats made by
America you know I'm I'm going to give
credit to to Biden for doing that it
could save lives but um but we got here
the reason we got here is because of the
American weakness over the last three
years I have no doubt I know we could do
this all day but uh you you have I am
sure plenty of things to do just just
two more questions for you can you just
describe because I think most people
watching this except and I think most
Americans except for a small crazy
minority except that if Donald Trump was
still president uh that this would not
have happened but can you describe what
it was like when you you were doing the
Abraham Accords talking to the Arab
counterparts and doing these deals that
no one said could ever be done could you
talk about what it was like to have
strong American leadership and why they
did it and sort of why when you have
weak American leadership they they won't
do this and it seems like the Saudi
Arabia thing is now it's probably kicked
down the can you know 10 years or
something well these countries whether
it was UAE or Bahrain or uh or Morocco
and and Saudi as well uh had enormous
respect for president Trump because uh
number one he kept his word when he said
he was going to do things number two all
these countries Israel included uh have
roughly the same enemies which are you
know radical radical Islamic terrorists
every one of these countries faces
radical Islamic terrorists and Donald
Trump you know in 2017 he goes to Saudi
Arabia and he speaks to 50 Arab
countries and says look you know what
we're all facing the same enemy but I
don't want to start dealing with them
when they cross the Atlantic it's your
job your job to to to stop these animals
before before they they they come my way
and if you do you'll find the United
States to be one of your best friends
and I think that changed the entire
Paradigm um when Trump uh took out kasum
sulamani who is the you know the head
terrorist among the country that is the
biggest state sponsor of terrorists
changed the dynamic people looked and
said wow you know wow look what this guy
did this guy was willing to uh to
directly to directly you know take out
the the the most popular leader in Iran
to send a to send a message that we will
not allow him to to proceed with plans
that he had underfoot to kill Americans
so you know that strength is what um is
what people are looking for it's not
what you say it's what you do and I
think in Trump um all these countries uh
Israel as well saw a reliable partner
that that was you know it's it's easy to
have a partner when you're when
everything's great you know like you got
a business partner you're making tons of
money everybody's friendly the question
is you know what kind of a partner do
you want when you're in the trenches you
when things are tough when when you have
to fight and you have to survive and you
have to Prevail who's the partner you
want and all these people would much
rather have Trump than Biden because
Trump trump is a guy that can that that
will fight and he's not afraid I I have
one more question for you because I'm
seeing a lot of people that seemingly
want to fall on the sword there's no win
for Israel here no matter what they do
and you can't win this war and all these
things what does a win for Israel now
look like to
you look I think um you know in in my
mind uh and I'm not a military
strategist or an expert but in my mind I
look at this I look at the I look at
Hamas as if they are uh as if they're
Nazis or or Isis or you know in that in
that category and um look in 19 you know
45 America and its allies defeated the
Nazis and we occupied uh Germany uh none
of the countries there wanted to hold
ger Germany but we occupied it for a
while we cleaned it out and then we uh
we turned it over to uh people that we
thought we could trust to build a nation
uh we help them and and look where we
are today we've got great relations of
course with Germany and Japan that to me
is sort of my model I mean we have to
clean it out okay and we have to
liberate uh
Gaza for the benefit of the people that
live there when Hamas is that and gone I
think you know uh I think Israel will
reach out to its neighbors will reach
out to America to the UN to try to
create a caretaker uh military uh
occupation for as long as is necessary
to turn it over to people that that want
to keep the Border quiet all Israel
wants is a quiet border doesn't have
doesn't want one inch of Gaza there's
not a single Jew living in Gaza there's
not a single military you know presence
in Gaza all Israel wants is a quiet
border once they're sure they can get
that they'll leave and then that will be
the
victory Ambassador I'm honored that you
took some time on obviously a very
difficult time you are welcome back
anytime you have our thoughts and
prayers and uh we will do this in the
promised land one way or another either
in the promised land where you are or
the other promised land of Florida where
you part-time live uh I I will see you
soon I
hope God bless you Dave thank you all
right guys so we're going to continue
for for just a little bit uh I hope that
gave a little historical not really just
historical perspective but a little
political perspective on kind of where
we're at and again why what I've been
trying to lay out over the couple days
is not let couple days it's not just ah
look at all the horrible things that
have happened and believe me and you
know they have happened it's like
there's a reason we got here there's a
reason this fight is on our doorstep and
we have to now unfurl the nonsense that
got us here and one of the reasons that
we are here is because over the last
well many people would say it's the last
40 years we have lost all of the
institutions in the United States when
Ambassador Friedman talks about his Alma
moders of Colombia and NYU going
radically radically left and supporting
decolonization and all of these things
and and now that BLM has come out for
terrorism and it basically is a domestic
Terror organization at this point and
all these things we shouldn't be
surprised at any of this right it was it
was it was there to see if you wanted to
see it and a lot of people again would
would rather put their head in the sand
and they're just the last ones to get
beheaded but one of the things that we
really have to come to grips with is
that we have about a half dozen
supporters of Hamas in our Congress now
they are the Hamas caucus they are all
Democrats we're talking about Rashida
Talib and AOC and ilhan Omar and Corey
Bush and uh Jamal Bowman and there's and
Ayanna Presley uh these are radically
anti-American Congress people who
believe that America is evil obviously
they believe that Israel is evil they
they churn out these duplicitous
statements you know condemning attacks
when when fundamentally they believe
these attacks are good and I want to get
into into that for just a little bit and
then we'll finish up with a few other
things but I want to throw back to
because Rashida Talib is probably the
worst of all you know it's hard to say
actually it's it we should probably
figure out a way maybe AI could figure
it out for how would you figure out
who's the worst between Rashida TB a uh
Rashida Talib AOC and uh and ilhan like
I don't know how you would do it maybe
we can get I have to get a mathematician
we should have a mathematician a
philosopher and a and a scientist come
on or something like that um anyway it
might be illan because I think she
married her brother but all right anyway
um reset uh here's Rashida TB a couple
years ago uh talking about how the
Holocaust gives her a calming feeling I
think two weeks ago or so we celebrated
um or just it took a moment I think in
our country to remember the Holocaust
and there's you know there's a kind of a
calming feeling I always tell folks when
I think of the Holocaust and the tragedy
of Holocaust and the fact that it was my
ancestors Palestinians who lost their
land and some lost their lives their
livelihood the human dignity um their
existence in many ways have been wiped
out and some people's passport I mean
just all of it was in the name of trying
to create a safe haven for Jews post um
the Holocaust post the tragedy and
horrific um persecution of Jews ac
across the world at that time and I love
the fact that it was my ancestors that
provided that right in many ways um but
they did it in a way that took their
human dignity away right and it was
forced on them and so when I think about
uh one state I think about the fact that
why couldn't we do it in a better way
man she is a psycho islamist everything
she said right there is a complete lie
except that it gave her a calming
feeling I do absolutely believe that the
death of six million Jews was a calming
feeling for her a couple things there
first off she accidentally said
celebrated the Holocaust Memorial so she
said celebrated then she backtracked on
that the calming feeling have you ever
in your life heard anyone say the
Holocaust gives me a calming feeling I
have a little tea have a little tea I
listen to some ambient music and I think
about the Holocaust um her ancestors
lost their land uh there were people
Jews Arabs Christians Muslims living in
Israel forever they lived under the
British uh Empire and again before that
under the Ottoman Empire the Western
Wall of the ancient Jewish temple is
thousands of years old why do they find
every time they dig a whole bunch of
stuff written in Hebrew Jews have been
there forever but then her implication
is but my ancestors they they somehow
gave them the land uh these people these
foreigners all showed up and they just
gave them the land and I'm so proud of
that uh actually the British said hey
we're we're we're done here we we're not
going to stay here anymore post World
War II the British Empire is collapsing
uh Jews you want some land Arabs again
there were no Palestinians at the time
would you guys want some land Google it
the 1947 un partition plan the Jews said
yes the Arabs said no and then all of
the Arab countries launched a war
including Rashida's family to kill the
Jews and some of the Arab countries said
hey you guys Arabs they weren't known as
Palestinians then get out of your houses
because we'll kill all the Jews and then
you can come back and those pesky Jews
somehow won and then they ended up with
more land ah tough what are you
going to do um so everything she says
there Li she's comforted that her her
family gave up they were like they
welcomed them in like it's just abject
lie but here she is yesterday this is so
profoundly vile except that it's obvious
right except that it's obvious here she
is this how long is this video about 60
seconds it's about 60 seconds she cannot
say a word about beheaded babies raped
women burned children Slaughter of
Innocence watch watch this rat watch
this rat Scurry
away terrorists have um cut off babies
heads and burn children alive do you
support Israel's rights to defend
themselves
against just going to go through there
you can't comment about Hamas terrorist
chopping off baby's
heads Congress do you have a comment on
Hamas terring off baby
head you have nothing to say about Hamas
terrorist popping out baby head
do you
condone what Hamas has done chopping off
babies Heads Burning children alive
raping women in the
street you have no comment about
children's heads being chopped
off Congressman why do you have the
Palestinian flag outside your office if
you do not condone what ter done to
Israel do Israeli lives not matter to
you first off before I comment on
Rashida and I have no doubt that you
guys were going through the words that I
might say about her in just a moment um
that that girl who I want to give an
awful lot of credit to there that is a
journalist and I can actually call her a
journalist which is so refreshing
without using air quotes her name is
Hillary vaugh and she works over at Fox
um that was about 60 seconds of a rat
scurrying away who simply cannot say you
know um baby's head's being chopped off
is pretty bad like why couldn't she stop
for one second and say you know I I
don't see the Israeli Palestinian
conflict the way you see it but yes
these tactics murdering pregnant women
like there's such an easy out here but
she can't do that because she is for it
she is for it and we don't have to
equivocate we need to stop being nice
you know there are too many of us too
many of us have just become sort of
amoral wishy-washy we will never stand
stand up for ourselves as the people
come to get us as the murderers calling
from inside the house and in this case
inside the House of
Representatives okay she could not just
say you know actually um obviously I'm
more on the Palestinian side of this
thing and okay generally that's
different than maybe what you guys think
at Fox but yeah B you know the burning
of babies the beheading of babies we can
all get on board that one and she can't
cuz she's for it but it's not just her
the the dishonest lock
that these people have spread not only
our politicians but our mainstream media
regarding this conflict the dishonest
way they cover this conflict and that
they do not tell you that there was
never a Palestinian state it never
existed who was the Prime Minister who
was the president there was an area
right it's also Babylon like I mean it's
just so mind-blowingly stupid and I know
and I saw a lot of comments over the
last couple days when I say these things
people are like holy cow is that true is
that is that true Googling things and
God only knows how long before Google
starts censoring all of what Googling
things and God only knows how long
before Google starts censoring all of
what actual history is but it's not just
the the Hamas caucus that that are awful
it is also our mainstream corporate
media the New York Times which has lied
about Israel and the founding of America
and Western values and has ushered in so
much of this crap uh here they are this
is from another guy that I'm proud to
call a journalist by the name of Greg
Price look at this holy you can't
make this up the New York Times
published a story referring to hamas's
terrorists and then changed it to gunman
I don't know how it even made it into
the New York Times in the first place
actually calling Hamas terrorist let me
let me read the headline for you Hamas
leaves Trail of Terror in Israel as
Israeli soldiers regain control of areas
near Gaza that came under attack they
are finding evidence seen in videos and
photos and confirmed by witness accounts
of the massacre of of civilians by Hamas
terrorists and of course as you can see
there then they changed it to Hamas
gunman I want you to think about this
for a second in any other Western nation
in any other Western Nation on Earth and
maybe not even any Western nation in any
other Nation on Earth if a bunch of guys
with guns and masks broke into a house
murdered babies all of the stuff if they
broke into houses in Greece and they did
it and if they broke into houses in
Chile and did it if they broke into
houses in Japan or South Africa everyone
would be calling them Terr it would not
be a debate but for the liberal
brainlets over at the New York Times
it's a debate I'm amazed actually quite
frankly that the first headline even
made it into the New York Times
somebody's probably getting beheaded
over there because of that but you can
see what they do you can see what they
do um okay we have a breaking headline
so I'm just reading this on the Fly this
is from The Wall Street Journal well I
guess this is another one of these types
of headlines Israel sought to contain
Hamas for years now faces a potentially
costly fight to eliminate it it's so
incredible the way they frame everything
as as Ambassador just laid out no Jews
live in Gaza 2005 took them all out
there were 8,000 there were 8,000 they
took them all out they said here are
your here are our green houses here are
our temples they ransacked all the
temples blah blah blah okay fine but now
it's Israel once again they want nothing
to do with these
people uh one of the I guess uh Silver
Linings of all of this is that some
people are wak up I played a clip of him
yesterday I'm going to play another clip
of him today and I hope it is not
shortlived Jake Tapper over at CNN who
who I think was the hope of CNN you know
he was on ABC before that he was the ABC
White House correspondent for many years
before he went over to CNN which was
must be a decade ago or so uh and he and
he sort of kept going more left on CNN
that's it breaks people's brains and
that's what it does to you but he's
doing a fine job of reporting right now
and I always think it's important when
when people even if they've been muddled
and Confused before when they start
coming around um you got to give them
credit so here is CNN's Jake Tapper uh
starting to push on the idea that boy
the left and the Democrats they really
have gone crazy with some of this
this does these last few days have been
a real eye openening period for a lot of
people a lot of Democrats a lot of
progressives in terms of anti-Semitism
on the left a lot of people who seem
more shocked at dehumanizing language uh
used by world leaders to describe Hamas
than what Kamas actually perpetrated on
Saturday yeah well it's not shocking to
some of us some of us have been saying
for a long time if you believe in
identity politics if you believe that
immutable characteristics are the most
important thing and if you don't have
any basis in biological reality or the
rest of it you might start thinking the
bad guys are the good guys you might
look at a minority of people that have
been programmed and Holocaust it across
the globe and go wait a minute how did
those Jews become successful how
did Adam Sandler make all those movies
Jews must be evil and then you might
find yourself at a rally in Dearborn
Michigan waving a Nazi flag so I want to
congratulate Jake and I and I would
encourage Jake to keep pushing keep
trying to show truth on CNN it ain't
going to be
easy uh got another headline here again
I'm getting some of this on the on the
Fly this is from The Wall Street Journal
and the Wall Street Journal is usually
pretty good uh scene of Massacre becomes
staging ground for Israel's invasion of
Gaza and then they use a quote I am
looking for Revenge well so it's the
onus is on the Israelis the Israelis
just want revenge you know they behead
and your wife and and burn your baby you
might want revenge it's just it's all so
incredible
um what am I looking at here sorry we're
doing a lot of this on the fly right now
yeah okay uh here is a a tweet by S bra
it's a random uh account on Twitter uh
but this is now what the leader of Hamas
is calling for at the moment uh be
advised the leader of Hamas just called
Muslims around the world to embrace a
day of global Jihad this Friday the 13th
Friday the 13th you know say that's
three days from now if you live in a
major city in America or Europe I'd
recommend avoiding crowded highly public
places on Friday please be safe uh one
more this is from broth Rashid on
Twitter khed Michal the leader and
founding member of Hamas gave a speech
today asking all Muslims around the
world to do the following to anger
especially next Friday in Muslim
countries and also among Muslim diaspora
around the world he called it the Friday
of alaa flood he said this will send a
message of Rage to zionists and to
America he asked for financial help from
all Muslims around the world to help
with their money he called it Financial
Jihad he asked for Muslims to give the
fighters of Gaza uh to give the fighters
of Gaza in order to compensate them for
the destruction uh three he asked for
political pressure from Muslim leaders
and Muslim nations to stop is Israel's
military invasion of Gaza four the most
important thing he asked all Muslims
around the world to carry Jihad by their
souls to fight and be Mars for Al AXA he
wants Muslims to fight against the Jews
starting with Muslims who live in the
countryes surrounding Israel Jordan
Syria Lebanon and Egypt but also other
countries to go to the borders and try
to enter each by his own means he said
this is time for Jihad to be applied on
the ground rather than just in theory he
asked the madin to go in Long Caravans
to spell their blood on the land
Palestine these are his final words
funds are important but today we are
asking for your blood and souls to be
sacrificed for
Palestine Friday the 13th um they're
telling you I want to be very clear
about one thing and I and I think it's
fairly freaking obvious if you have ever
followed me um I have no doubt that the
average Muslim person and your neighbor
and your friend and all of those things
are peaceful people and I have Muslim
neighbors and friends and all of those
things and I have for my entire life we
are fighting a radical Twisted ideology
right now a warped Twisted ideology that
is celebrating blood and murder and
Mayhem and medieval barbarity that the
world has not seen literally since the
Holocaust but they were doing this to
Jews before the Holocaust right they
were doing right before sorry they were
doing this to Jews before the state of
Israel and now Israel exists and they're
still doing it we better start M waking
up to this uh believe me there was way
more we could have done on the show
today I really want to link and I think
we'll do some of this tomorrow I want to
link some of this to what's going on at
the border right now and as Ambassador
fredman said it's like why wouldn't we
think that Iran has pushed people
through our border like these things are
deeply connected there was a rally in
Dearborn Michigan which is Rashida
talib's um we can't grab that video
quickly we'll do it tomorrow okay we
we'll do it tomorrow uh there was a
rally at a uh at a theater thousands of
people uh in Dearborn Michigan which is
Rashid talib's District waving Hamas
Flags calling for Jihad like here in
America it's kind of 1938 Nazi stuff so
what are we going to do I don't know
what we're going to do I I actually
don't know what we're going to do um but
you better wake up you better wake up um
all right I want to thank Ambassador
fredman again and uh again the the link
to one of there's many obviously many
places that you can donate uh the link
to the one that I mentioned which is
this Miami organization that the the the
funds will go directly to the soldiers
again it's called heart uh donated this
morning the funds go directly to the
soldiers and the families impacted uh
that link is down below we're going to
do a postgame show in just a second at
Ruben report. locals.com and I said to
the guys I was like how how are we going
to end with the worldes day you know
like come on man um and I have friends
coming into town this weekend you know
it's like the worst time for worldwide
Jihad and and Phoenix said Dave I got
you covered we got a funny one to let
let everybody out with so here you go
and we'll see everybody at the post game
are not that they're asking what's your
advice to the next next house
Speaker I need to get my diaper changed
right
[Music]
now